hallo herzlich willkommen
ok sally uns amiras welt heute backen
wir scones und zwar ins tor
das ist ein englisches gebäck wird oft
zur teatime serviert und man kann sie
entweder neutral herstellen oder so wie
bei mir jetzt mit brombeeren also ich
habe heute bombast und dazu gibt's ein
bombay curtis bombeck hat ist ein
fruchtaufstrich den man zum beispiel
morgens aufs brot schmieren kann oder
eben für den stones dazu servieren kann
und das ganze schmeckt werde ich super
fruchtig und dies kann sind super
schnell hergestellt mit nur ganz wenigen
grundzutaten deswegen würde ich sagen
zeige ich euch jetzt die zutaten und du
zu mir hilfst du mir dabei
ok ok samira super machst du das und ich
sage euch die zutaten für disco für den
sonst brauche ich 450 gramm mehl 2
teelöffel backpulver einen viertel
teelöffel salz 100 gramm zucker etwa 100
bis 150 milliliter kalte milch ein
eiweiß 125er garten eine unbehandelte
limette und 200 gramm tiefgefrorene
bombay bei den zutaten ist es ganz
wichtig dass sie ganz kalt sind und
deswegen darf die samira die brombeeren
jetzt wieder ins gefrierfach stellen
denn tiefgekühlte fürchte die werden
dann immer ganz schnell matschig wenn
sie auftauchen
ich will mich zuerst einmal das mehl und
da kommen jetzt alle trockenen zutaten
dazu also salz zucker und ihr könnt den
teig jetzt entweder mit der
küchenmaschine zubereiten oder auch mit
den händen oder so wie wir das mit den
werten mit einem hacker super die
zutaten vermischen wir miteinander
super da kommt jetzt noch das eiweiß mit
dazu
jetzt kleckern ist seit
beim teig ist jetzt ganz wichtig dass er
immer nur ganz kurz verknetet wird dann
wieder nicht warm wird
ok reicht schon es kommt noch der garten
mit rein
da kommt noch die limettenschale mit
rein vielleicht ganz toll
mit der hacke ich den teig so lange bis
sich alles gut verbunden hat
jetzt kommt noch die milch mit dazu und
da kommt jetzt darauf an wie groß es war
also ändern braucht die 100 oder bis zu
150 milliliter ja dazu noch ein bisschen
stoff und im teig verknetet jetzt bis
große brocken am tag zu sehen
ich mache es ganz kurz
ja
und der titans beim fertig wie eben mit
den händen zusammendrückt und er
zusammen bleibt und da muss jetzt noch
mal für etwa eine halbe stunde in den
kühlschrank und in der zwischenzeit
können wir schon mal dass robert machen
für das rhomberg hat brauche ich 200
gramm beeren die limette die ich vorhin
verwendet habe eine zitrone 200 gramm
zucker einen teelöffel stärke und nur
125 gramm care garten
jetzt sehen wir zuerst einmal die
brombeeren die kommen jetzt hier rein
denn die zutaten für das fromberg hört
weil du jetzt zuerst repariert die
brombeeren die könnt ihr wenn ihr daran
denkt woher auch einfach kurz auftauen
lassen
jetzt kommt auch der saft der limone
dazu eindrücke zusammen wie viel stärker
okay du bist du stark
den ganzen saft aus langstrumpf
was sich den vielen fehlern wenn ich auf
die arbeitsplatte schneien
so jetzt stoppt und jetzt auf
jetzt kommen auch die restlichen zutaten
dazu also dem zucker und da könnt ihr
jetzt 40 bis 100 gramm nehmen je nach
dem system bambergern sind die eier und
die speisestärke und die zutaten werden
es kurz püriert
die bombe mischung ist fein püriert und
die fülle ich jetzt in einen kleinen
topf und lasse dann bei mittlerer hitze
eindecken das dauert dann so etwa fünf
bis sieben minuten
jetzt ist das fromberg hat eingedeckt
und durfte jetzt einmal ganz kurz
aufkochen und jetzt kommt noch care
gaben mit rein und zwar belebt es dann
dass es nach dem abkühlen wieder fest
wird aber trotzdem aus dem kühlschrank
herausstreicht bleibt denn das comeback
hört ist ja auch ein brotaufstrich den
man zum beispiel morgens seien ganz gut
essen kann aufs brot oder eben auch zu
den skulpturen
deshalb so heißt
das vom berg will ich jetzt um und zwar
gibt es drei gläser mit 220 millimeter
viel inhalt fassungsvermögen
das frauenwerk stelle ich jetzt zum
abkühlen auf die seite und sobald es
zimmertemperatur angenommen hat kommt in
den kühlschrank und jetzt können wir die
stones bereits formen
so gibt es zudem beim holen okay der
tiger selbst abgekühlt und den will ich
jetzt hier oder lehre ihn auf eine
silikon matte ihr könnt aber auch auf
der ganz normalen arbeitsplatte arbeiten
jetzt kommen die ganz kleinen brombeeren
mit dazu die werden jetzt mit dem teig
so ein bisschen verknetet aber der tag
da jetzt nicht durchgeknetet werden das
heißt er muss smart sie schön kalt
bleiben und die brombeeren die zackig
jetzt noch ein bisschen
der teig mittels halbiert das geht jetzt
auch super einfach es war formen jetzt
daraus einen kreis das war nicht ganz
die hälfte genaue zu formen
aber nicht zu warm machen den teig okay
und der tag sollte jetzt etwa 2 5 bis 3
cm hoch sein
und alles was jetzt noch tun müsst ist
ein messer zu nehmen und das ganze in
acht kuchenstücke zu verteilen
und die fertigen stone setzt sich jetzt
hier auf ein backblech das habe ich mit
ner back folie einfach belegt
genau dieses chaos kommt jetzt im
backofen und zwar bei 200 grad ober
unterhitze in den vorgeheizten ofen für
etwa 20 bis 25 minuten und in der zeit
vom aufräumen
dies sind jetzt gebacken und ich glaube
der murat freut sich schon darauf sie
probieren zu dürfen jetzt will ich mal
gespannt was auf dem teller legen
ich will ganz spanien sagen in alisas
von bekannt immer und zwar gibt die
mittagszeit heim und dann serviert man
sie auch mit marmelade zum beispiel
strawberry jam freund und deswegen geht
es bei umsätzen in homberg hört ich
finde die farbe übrigens richtig toll
und es sind ja drei gläser also können
natürlich auch eine kleinere menge
machen aber man kann eben auch im
kühlschrank lagern bis zu einer woche
und es morgens und mittags essen darf
ich übrigens eine englische freundin von
uns grüßen die petra robbins stimmt
genau welches bestimmt auch bei uns mit
genau wie bh jetzt schau mal wie sally
die englischen stars gemacht hat genau
und dem rad da jetzt probieren gehen das
macht er noch genau hier noch mit
typisch probiert schon mal die sind noch
leicht war es nicht gerade genial
also man kann sie warm essen oder auch
kalt ich bin beides gut
möchtest du probieren sie mir an und
zwar ich bin jetzt ein level könnt ich
probieren die hat zum wald hat der berg
kürze so vom leben kürzer weil es genau
dieses typische säuerliche hat und dann
nichts kunst dazu mit dem brunnen bernd
genial allerdings auch richtig toll und
vor allem farblich wunderschön hier also
richtig schön und richtig toller socken
also man kann natürlich auch wenn man
jetzt keine bomben mag oder keine hat
kann man natürlich auch himbeeren nehmen
oder kirschen oder im künftig alles was
man zu hause hat aus dem tiefkühlfach
oder natürlich auch frische beeren
man kann natürlich auch
dieses körper einfach nur ohne es bei
uns essen genau als brotaufstrich genau
wie sein kollege schicht ja also wir
wünschen euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen und wir sehen uns dann das
nächste mal wieder da habe ich von
seiner milch trinken samira parlament
haben ja ich glaube mich schon richtig
ich glaube dieser muss mal kurz mal hin